we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day many people do call at
very unusual times of day at least for
people who are in american time zones i
guess who would say let's take a listen
to the voicemail that came in today
hi david just wondering if you've ever
touched on the subject of the growing
population of the earth and if what your
thoughts are on that and if you think
it's going to be an environmental
catastrophe seems like a very taboo
subject to discuss anyway thanks well
this show i don't know that it's taboo I
mean we've interviewed experts about the
concept of overpopulation there's sort
of two answers to that right from a
strictly mathematical perspective the
carrying capacity of the earth is not
even close to like not even remotely
close to being approached even slightly
on the basis of potential resources on
the basis of energy demand etc if and
this is a big if we start to actually
take more seriously reducing our carbon
footprint and energy consumption the
concern is that if the major sort of
carbon consumers and polluting countries
don't make big changes in terms of
reducing carbon footprint if we don't
start moving away from fossil fuels to
power home heating and automobiles and
airplanes and so many other modern sort
of industrialized technologies then yes
we are you could actually argue in that
case that we've already reached a
population which based on current
average carbon use and energy
consumption is taxing the planet so
we've got a lot of headroom if we start
making the changes that climatologists
and climate scientists and others have
been saying we need to make for decades
at this point if we don't start doing
that then we are actually going to have
an over a so-called overpopulation
problem which won't really be an
overpopulation problem it'll be an over
energy consumption problem in reality
yeah I know that if you stand to
everyone in the world
shoulder-to-shoulder go dial you can fit
them all within Rhode Island but I guess
we need more resources than just being
able to stand up straight yes so it is a
little bit more than that and
also I guess this topic can be taboo
even if you're not talking about like
killing people for population control
because I think it's generally thought
of that you want to like limit the
amount of children that people can have
the kind of one-child policy yeah and
yeah that can be taboo well we once got
a call during live calls about and from
an anti-natal list asking if I am an
subscribe to anti-natal list philosophy
and believe that we should simply stop
procreating because of all the problems
that were causing and and at the time I
thought it was relatively
uncontroversial for me to say no I think
there's lots of other things we can just
fix rather than saying we're going to
exterminate or basically allow the human
race to go extinct and actually took
some heat from that a lot of people
saying David how dare you suggest humans
keep reproducing Wow and pronatalist
yeah I'm in favor of humans continuing
to have children it's crazy on the bonus
show today we will talk about Finland
having second thoughts about their basic
income experiment we'll talk about a
monkey losing a selfie copyright case
and there's actually a lot of
interesting broader copyright questions
there and we will also talk about how a
quote real Indian is now running against
senator Elizabeth Warren supposedly a
fake Indian if you've not familiarized
yourself with the story of Elizabeth
Warren's Native American background we
will familiarize you with it on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show both ways to access the
bonus show which is coming up next